Hello, everyone.
Welcome to
Active Inference Lab
Livestream number 46.2.
It's June 22nd, 2022.
Welcome to the ActInfLab.
We're a participatory online lab
that is communicating,
learning and practicing
applied active inference.
You can find us
at the links on the slide.
This is a recorded
and archived livestream,
so please provide us with feedback
so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds
and perspectives are welcome
and we'll
follow video etiquette for livestreams.
Head over to active inference
dot org
to learn about participating
in livestreams
or in the many other active
lab projects.
We're here
in our third discussion on the paper.
Active inference models
do not contradict
folk psychology
by Smith, Ramstad and Kieffer.
We had a zero with Ryan joining
and Jacob and Dean where we talk through
some of the backgrounds of this paper.
And last week in the Dark One,
we had a great discussion,
went a lot of ways as dot ones do,
and opened up some threads
to continue discussing in this start to.
I know each of you
have some things to bring up.
There's also
a few key
sections of the paper
that we haven't gone
into in much detail.
So there'll be a lot to do in the data.
And of course, everybody watching
live is also welcome to make comments.
We'll start
with just an introduction and warm up.
We can say hi and add
anything else
that we're looking forward
to talking about
or to reducing our uncertainty
about through today's discussion.
Or maybe even if it's not too early
where we'd like to be heading as we
take off on this Dark
two and leave the 46 series.
How does it
results in us
being different,
thinking differently,
actually differently
in the rest of our post 46 lives.
So I'm Daniel.
I'm a researcher in California and
just a conversation with Dean
before we began
about some other core concepts
other than beliefs, desires
and intentions.
So what other acronym models
could we use?
What other kinds of models
are consistent?
Or where else can active
inference be providing us extra
information or utility?
And a few other things.
And I'll pass it to Dean
instead of I'm Dean
in Calgary.
I think what I'm
curious about is a couple of things.
As I said, I'm
I'm curious about things are behaviors
that appear to be targeted versus
behaviors
that appear to be non-targeted.
And there was there was
there's some reference
to that in this paper.
The other thing is
they said,
I'm kind of curious about is this moving
to the place of saying that
active inference
has these different types,
be it extended or
decision making or motor
active inference,
and what the implications of that are.
The bottom line for me
is I think if we can
operationalize that word
through active inference,
it shouldn't be difficult to figure out
that that applies to behaviors,
that there's operations
grounding a lot of behavior.
So yeah, that's
what I'm kind of curious about
has to do with
the great to be back.
It's my second time on here.
I really appreciate this.
I'm on
33, so I've listened through lecture 33,
so I'm almost caught up to
the current.
I look forward to having Daniel
in my channel Friday 4 p.m.
Eastern time.
And there's so much to active inference
because it's
a useful framework for countless
different fields.
And specifically related to this,
I had your definitely thoughts.
And then how do we look at the
mechanics of the equation
versus, you know,
we call folk psychology,
but I would put that generally into a
what I would call introspection.
I have a background in theology
and I find a lot about introspection
and trying to match
what we see through various methods of
introspection and
maybe where the science and
mathematics is leading us.
And also,
I guess, the field of psychometrics
that isn't necessarily introspection,
but it may or may not
match the equations.
And then how do we describe
the phenomenon?
You understand them,
or maybe they're not descriptive
those that we describe them
with the mathematical equations,
and there's not really any good way
to translate that into words.
That would be
you'll understand, able to use folk
and people in that way.
Awesome. Ali
Hi, I'm Ali.
I'm an independent researcher from Iran.
I'm very glad to be here and I'm
looking forward to learn more about
this fascinating paper,
especially interested in exploring
phenomenological aspects of body,
I believe, desire and intention,
and also to explore
somewhat more deeply the philosophical
underpinnings of representation versus
simulation aspect of modeling.
VDI in active inference.
And
that's it for me.
Great.
Let's
begin with this more taxonomic question
about the types of active inference
so we can think about
the different types
that we've heard about
in this paper and elsewhere, and then
whether or not
we have something to contribute
about adding
a specific type to this list
that will continue to grow,
what does it mean or entail
that we do have these different types?
So just to review in this paper 46,
they make a very clear
upfront distinction
between what they characterize
as motor
active and I and decision active.
And there's a few differences
between motor and decision
who can list one category
of difference?
Well, the motor active inference
doesn't typically require
that you have to make a decision.
It's more reaction or reflective
form
as compared to the
decision active inference,
which does as the papers say,
likely map over to the desire.
QUESTION Yes.
So the motor
I was connected to like motor reflex
are their decision making reflex.
Does even if that's not
a classical usage
like in the reflex
arc of the spine or something,
moving the hand away from a hot surface
are their cognitive reflexes
not really sharp.
I just basically was asking that
in the context of people
who are writing these papers now,
who are bringing the question down
to it,
a motor operational behavior standpoint,
how breaking active inference up
into different classifications
is that in response to a bigger problem,
which is
the behavior doesn't necessarily
even or doesn't necessarily
isn't something
that's necessarily
we able to conveniently dissolve
down to or concentrate on
into motor operations
or extensions
or any of those
other different things
that that
that the writers tend
to want to focus on now
as opposed to sort of the complexity
and the variety
and the randomness of behavior
as a whole.
So, yes, great.
So this is from page
81.
Oh, yes, I'll go for it.
Well, I think the distinction between
may I and I
is not
globally accepted among,
well, various researchers.
For instance,
if we look at the work of Alan
Bartels, the French
neuroscientist, especially his book,
I think it was called
The Brain's Sense of Movement.
In that book, he actually
has a famous quote,
namely, perception is simulated action.
And by this
he means that
he implies
that perception
and motion and motion and perception
or thinking for that matter,
are irreducibly interconnected.
And so
the former
the former defines the latter
because of the intrinsic monstrosity
of the creatures
endowed with nervous systems.
So I'm not sure if we can
distinguish between May I and I
in such a clear cut manner,
because as we know that most motor
and most
mattress, city and motor
or actions are also
pretty predefined in that perception
and or many other thought processes.
Thanks.
Do it.
Yes. So I didn't know enough about
the BDA model or the
you know,
I'm still new to the language,
especially of the authors of this paper,
to the general philosophy
I was talking a lot about last week,
about the unified
I and higher order rules.
So if you want to look like decision
as higher order rules
and they would have some sort of
power like usually
when we think of consciousness
in a unified way that makes decisions
and I think
we talked about a limited wisdom
and the implications of the equations
are the element of a stick or not and
yours is there.
What,
what direction does
the evidence take us?
And so in terms of motor control,
like I mentioned, photos, a
modular mind that it could be that,
you know, it's
a threshold, it's
a free energy principle
and it could just be actually
action, reaction, sense perception.
And then a module of our mind sends you
some perception of what, however,
we understand consciousness
that makes it appear to us
like we made a decision.
Pardon me, but that may not be accurate
that the,
you know,
the equations might hint
that that's not actually
what's going on.
It's simply free energy threshold
being reached.
The threshold could conceivably
have nothing or very little to do
with the decision making process,
and it could be post facto like that.
The experiments
that the perception
might be made a decision
actually comes post facto
from the threshold.
Cool.
Thank you. Also, I think
Adam Safran, who had discussed those lab
experiments, does
find a space for agency,
if that's not too,
of course, of a simplification.
But there is some
interesting ways to think about what
that experiment does or doesn't show.
We can return to that
when we kind of
have some figures and details in.
Yeah, I didn't know what you guys
were talking about with this.
A limited Ms.
thing till I went back to the paper
and then I found this
and I'll just quote it
We all this is from the paper.
We also motivated squarely non a
to best position
with respect to such constructs
and suggests
that the set of theoretical primitives,
out of which
the active inference models are built,
is sufficient
not only to recover the categories
of folk psychology,
but also to potentially
nuance them
with more fine grained distinctions.
So I don't I'm not sure exactly what how
what you've been saying
either corresponds with that or not.
But I'm kind of curious.
Yeah, go for it.
Yeah.
I mean, to me, it's a fallacy that
you're like a
best of both worlds fallacy that
a material is like research
into consciousness make.
Is that in reality,
my understanding of the
the conclusions of what they're saying
is that it is a limit of best
and they'll put a little statement
in like it's not a limited list,
but what is the evidence of their models
actually say and can they actually
program like a unified a
and you to put that
did they eliminate the unified
I and it's just a bunch of perceptions
and various factors
that reach a threshold
and what does it mean to
make a decision so
and that's why I said do
we just throw away
thousands of years of dualistic theology
and
how people your whole lexicon of
consciousness psychology
comes from a dualistic tradition.
So, you know,
if they're trying to grandfather
in these
dualistic concepts,
but even the evidence
of what they're saying
doesn't necessarily seem to warrant it.
And then, you know,
do they have the courage to be like, no,
unfortunately, the evidence points
to a limited wisdom and go with that.
So, I mean, in my impression
they can just throw in the statement,
but it's unclear how they're,
you know,
how they're doing it because, you know,
I guess,
you know, it's going to be unpopular
to be an element of us.
It's kind of like
the free will question that.
I mean,
the element of wisdom
also relates to free will.
But to stand up and be like,
no, I'm sorry, free will doesn't exist.
That's where the evidence is pointed,
sort of put in there.
That they're not trying to say that.
But you're my impression.
I think they actually are trying
to say that in looking
for that's
where the evidence of their conclusions
are saying.
And they just have a human weakness
that doesn't want to go so far
as to follow the evidence of,
you know, their research.
Interesting.
So just to continue on this motor
and decision.
So page five, may
I just not make decisions
once a decision has
been made about what to do?
And may I use this
proprioceptive prediction
signals to move the body
to carry out the decided action sequence
and elsewhere.
We've talked about that sort of
set point
and then a
transient suppression of precision
which allows the body
to reach this new spatial position.
And also these models
have tended to be formulated
in continuous time,
whereas decisioning eye
plugs in very nicely to the motor eye
because it is explicitly considering
decision
making in these higher order rules
that have to do with either.
If you take a more realist perspective
what organisms
or cognitive systems are doing,
or the more instrumental perspective,
which is just
this is how the
the process of decision
making can be modeled.
And it's about which decisions are made
about what
to do in order
to generate some observations
and not others. And it's that
focus on the
observations that are generated
under different courses of action
and their evaluation
in terms of expected free energy.
That also ties
it closely
to like perceptual control theory.
So that's the distinction they bring up.
And again, whether in the real world
this carves cognitive systems
at that point is one question
in the world of the theories
as constructed,
this is a clean separation,
although as Ali brought up, that doesn't
mean that it's some widely accepted
or even if everybody heard about it,
that they would
necessarily agree with it.
And there may be phenomena
that are mixtures,
and that's also why they talk
about the hybrid models,
where it's like decision
making at a higher level
and then motor at a lower level.
So that could allow decisions
about what
section of a face
to look at
or what section of the page to read,
and then that decision
becomes implemented
in a continuous motor
active inference context
through ocular motor action. Then
yeah, I'm not I don't think I'm,
I don't think
I'm leading with this question about
are we moving to a place that says that
active inference
will have different types
because they think
that there's different
there's a
there's math
that's used in financial situations.
Those operations,
there's math
that's used in mechanical situations,
those operations.
So I think it's
it's a natural byproduct of so
how do you make the math work
given the circumstance?
I don't think that
there's anything about this that's
saying active inference doesn't work
just because you want to make sure
that you're applying the proper formula
to the thing
that you're trying to describe.
But I do think it's interesting that
in order to be able
to describe it
more precisely,
you just can't say active inference.
You have to kind of figure out
what the math is
for the specific condition
that we're trying to analyze.
Yeah, definitely makes sense.
Let's now
move to this lower part of the page
on the different adjectives
that we've seen
so people can probably add
or think of more or even imagine
there's so many adjectives
in the
in the textbook called the dictionary.
We've talked about extended
active inference,
which was addressing extended
cognitive features and phenomena
where there could be
sort of a offloading,
which was when the adaptive
active entity
is going to utilize
something that is more like a notepad,
like it's
offloading memory onto the notepad,
and then the entity is
holding on to information
about how to seek that information
or on both sides of the interface,
there could be adaptive, active.
And so that was like
the sort of true
emergence, extended cognitive processes,
deep active inference and
citations could be
could be at it
didn't get them for all deep
was utilized to describe temporal depth
in terms of longer
and longer time
horizons of considerations.
This was really an important development
because it moved
beyond the sort of one shot
next step model of active
and help manage
this tradeoff
between considering time horizons
as well as taking action in the time
step that the entity is actually in
sophisticated active inference
and various other
cousins of it
utilized, hierarchical modeling
which could have temporal depth
at one or multiple levels
but doesn't need to.
It does and it could.
But this is referring to
like the thickness
or the hierarchical modeling component,
affective active inference,
which was used by a hospital
to refer to uncertainty parameters
and some of the cognitive
interpretations
of uncertainty parameters
as being related to surveillance.
And then there's others
like branching time, active infants.
It comes to what Dean said,
which is just saying, like we use
active inference
may not reduce uncertainty enough
anymore.
Then we used a linear model,
whether just talking about it
casually or
writing the paper,
more information has to be provided.
And so this is sort of
this is starting
to starting to build the taxonomy
and the classifications
and the ways of communicating,
reducing uncertainty.
Okay. You went to that hemisphere.
Was it this continent or that continent?
Was it this coast or was it
that like zooming in,
ultimately resulting
in just describing
the particulars of the model
that was constructed early?
Well, adding to what
Dean has just said, well,
I don't think
that these different flavors
and versions of active inference
that have recently been
recently in branch of
the they don't necessarily
concern themselves
with different situations
or different niches.
For example, that last one branching
time, active inference.
Well, that was a very recent version
of active inference, which was, yes,
this is the paper, uh,
they introduced that
and it's basically a more efficient
computational approach
to active inference
and it's just
the traditional active inference,
but in a more efficient,
with a more efficient
algorithm to compute
the, all the parameters needed.
Yes.
Sometimes
it's these adjectives are describing
heuristics or implementations
or algorithms.
Other times
they're describing the model structure,
other times
they're referring to the context
that the model's being applied to,
like an extended cognitive system.
Yeah, that's.
That's what I was going to
ask Ali about.
So if I'm saying
something more efficient,
what am I saying?
It's more efficient relative to
well, relative to
the traditional approach
to active inference
that has been proposed
for the past decade or two.
And also relative to the other
and the other approaches
that are similar to active inference
as approach with not
if not exactly equivalent to it
instance reinforcement and reinforcement
learning approaches and so on.
And one other
kind of analogy or mapping
there would be like
when a new variant of a neural network
architecture is introduced,
there's a pomp and circumstance
to announce the novelty
and the relevance of this
for somebody who's in that field.
Similarly, when there's a new variants
or a new focus, whether model structure,
model target
or something else
related to evolutionary biology,
sometimes a new word will come in,
but then
that new
target or model structure,
if it becomes used
and it's sufficiently closed
that it's not rejected
from the rest of the body of theory
give, it's
an incoherent usage of the adjective.
Someone says,
Well, I made, you know,
simple active inference,
and it has this totally
different structure
that might not become incorporated
into the
the network of active inference models,
whereas if it does become incorporated
through its theoretical compatibility
or utility in modeling that phenomena
or it's presented in terms of a model
architecture that does apply elsewhere,
the adjective kind of gets dropped
and then it just goes back
to being neural networks, back
to being active inference, back
to being evolutionary biology,
and then the field moves on.
And so
the adjectives
are just kind of like
another brick in the wall.
Do it.
You also mentioned last week,
I'm not sure if it would go here in
this section is the purpose driven.
The
purpose driven behavior
action or event
perception related to a unified AI?
And
even if it's on the pure
level of sense perception,
is it just that we have,
you know, these procedures
and they perceive
and then how are the signals read and
I mean, it's easier
to describe this
in a element of a static way,
whether we're limited of it or not.
In the per,
the predictive mind is the main
struggle, so to say, between short
term goals and long term goals.
And then you have to put in
what axioms are we making?
Is there some sort of
for the higher order rules
if we assume that there's
some sort of rule that like an organism
acts in its own self-interest
and its own a sort of, say, desire
to survive or to replicate.
And then you
the only struggle would be between short
term and long term
actions, like,
you know,
God forbid, here
we have a mosquito pandemic
that was gardening
and got eaten up by mosquitoes.
And for just a sense,
you're replying to the environment
like I have an itch, try it.
Should
or should I have some longer term
that will go away quicker
if if I don't, it should.
And is that something
that's even in the subconscious?
We're just naturally
I would have an itch
and I would itch it,
but then I would
somehow enter
a longer term decision making process
that would tell me to act
in a different way.
And even the terms
for how I'm going to interact
with the environment in the future,
let alone
something that might have
a moral or ethical implication.
So if we have a simplified model of just
where do we need purpose
for sense perception to work
and for motor control
to work even in terms of reflexes,
I think you're just
even on the motor control,
let alone the decision making.
Where does the decision making go
and what's the purpose behind it?
And then how is that purpose derived?
Yes.
So we can go to targeted non targeted.
Another
branch point is
I think this important question of
mapping from real world phenomena
and even direct felt experiences
like esthetic
or just more generally phenomenological
and anything about a formalism.
And I'm not sure
if I've quoted too narrowly,
but they are writing that intentions.
So just to review the
by the beliefs and desires come together
and that is what generates
the intention.
There's the desire for the ice cream
and there's the belief
that there's the ice cream truck.
And that is what generates
the intentional behavior
of like pursuing the ice cream truck.
Intentions map
straightforwardly to policies
with lowest value
for expected free energy,
which is calculated across
different policies.
Policies are
affordances that can be taken
over a given time horizon.
So over time
horizon of three
is the combination
of affordances of length three.
Almost all of the variables
in the design
model
are candidates
for traditional psychological beliefs.
If being used to model
the right kinds of high level
cognitive processes.
So what are the right kinds?
But then later in footnote five,
this is distinguishing in a
what they characterize as a different
reading of desire.
This reading is not the thing
that is desired,
but instead about the transient presence
of the motivational force
to approach the thing we desire.
So it's like, why did you go there?
It was my desire to go there.
What moved you to go there?
Desire.
So it's almost like desire
in the specifics
and then also seeing it
as a motivating force.
But then
they note
that have
it might not have a direction to fit
and it illustrates
another reason consistent
with our broader argument
concerning desires not to assume
that probability distributions
in the formalism must be mapped
onto beliefs. The psychological level.
So they're candidates.
If we do it right.
But it isn't an assumption
that they must be mapped on to beliefs.
Ali, I well,
I wanted to mention the
broader sense
of the term intentionality,
which I think here is referred to,
because you see,
for all the entities defined by
market blankets and defined by
the existence
of their market
blankets and their ergodic behavior,
well, we need an entity who can treat
an effect as being about its cost.
You see
an entity who can follow the direction
from effect to cause.
And and we also need an entity
who can treat an ice morphic map
as being about what it maps
or, let's say, is oriented toward
what it maps.
Well, in both of these cases,
the directionality or orientation
can be referred to as intentionality.
And it's brought sense.
So just to clarify,
there's the second piece
you mentioned was
the entity needs to be able
to treat some sort of ice and morphic
or structure preserving, mapping
as having an about ness of the target
like the map of the city,
translating that into
the physical movement.
And then
there is a causal inference question
entity can trace causes
such that they understand
such that they're doing
some kind of causal mapping
where agency is the belief
that one can be the cause
of future aspects.
So is this agency
or is this causal modeling
that could happen
in the absence of entity level agency?
I think it's more it's broader than
necessarily
that being a cognitive agent,
you see it's any abstract entity
that can
that can sketch out
these kind of causal relationships
between
between the signs and they're either
icons or they're indices.
So
it's much broader and more abstract
than necessarily cognitive agents.
What kind of entity use
are you thinking of?
And isn't manipulation
and and not kind of logical
juxtaposition?
No, no.
The one
obvious example
would be neural networks.
In neural nets.
We don't necessarily bestow
upon neural networks a cognitive agency.
Right.
But they can well match the
at least their input patterns
onto their outputs,
like output indices.
And it's
these continuum
of agency, continuum
of cognitive systems.
It's like easy to forget.
We're, we're
talking about
a cognitive modeling framework,
albeit one that has a motor cousin MRI
and motor
motor modeling history.
Because the MRI distinction is
also historical, like in terms of what
which models were developed when
and
is this pattern cognitive ism?
Are we modeling everything as if it is
on the continuum
of cognitive entities like
I don't know if it's as controversial
as say,
that a neural network
is a cognitive artifact.
It might not be self-perpetuating
or embodied
or have open ended agency
or all these other features
that some cognitive systems have.
But
what makes it not cognitive.
If you meant that.
Well, probably the cognitive here
was not a proper, proper adjective.
Perhaps what I meant was to be,
I don't know,
a kind of conscious agent or
but again, on the the subject of
using the adjective cognitive
or neural networks,
well, there are quite a few.
Well, opponents
to this
characterization from neural networks
because they believe
that neural networks as agents
don't necessarily
decide and their cognitive
a decide on their cognitive basis how to
map out how to
you see
map between the inputs and outputs,
because that's the difference
between representation
and simulation if we well
can differentiate
between between those two.
So probably
the more suitable adjective here
should be a conscious agent
as opposed to cognitive agents.
Does that not take us extremely
far afield out of where we
lose touch with empirical measurements?
For example, and enter into important
philosophical questions,
but ones that take us like
away from our cognitive leg
and psychology,
perhaps even
especially folk
psychology, is sitting
at the intersection
of cognitive systems,
philosophical self-reflexive systems.
So it's almost like a question of
this teetering stack of folk psychology.
Which way will it end up falling?
A limited
ism perhaps is saying
we'll be able to dispense
with classical philosophical debates
or some aspects of them
by just moving everything that was folk
psychological into a mathematical
cognitive framework.
What I mean here is that, well,
the term intentionality here
can also be used in
in abstract models
of active inference and not necessarily
well in the cases where we
unambiguously deal with
conscious entities.
That's what I mean.
I think one of the takeaways
of this paper
or one of the implications of this paper
would be that if intentions
in folk psychology
are beliefs plus desires,
hashtag PDA, model, and beliefs
and desires
are identifiable quantities
in the active formalism.
Then by
constructing entities consistent
with the act in formalism,
it can be said
that they have intentionality
because it could be said
that they have beliefs and desires.
And so then it would only make sense
to call the behaviors
arising from beliefs and desires
to be intentional.
So doesn't this conceptualization
of intentionality also subsume
the a more strict
or narrow sense of that term?
Because, well, if we
in this sense, if we infer in the
from the use of intentionality here
as referring to only conscious agency.
Well in that case the
the whole purpose of simulating
active inference agents
could potentially
well raise some questions.
That's. Well,
I'm not sure if I could
express myself
clearly on this matter or not, but.
Oh, no, very interesting of Dean.
And then do it.
So maybe among the three of you,
you can help me with this,
because I don't really keep up
with the latest news on neural nets. But
if I
if I were to look at a neural net,
I would assume that
most of those nets are given
some kind of a target,
even if they go out and forage for it.
There is something about that.
But what I've
always been curious about is,
especially in the context of this paper,
is that
if there is a target that's been
sort of linked to desire in this paper,
and if there's
a curiosity aspect to the agent
or the net
that's been
sort of linked to non targeting.
So if that's it, that's one continuum.
The orthogonal aspect of that
also in the paper
is that there's a reward
component, say on the left of that
there is an information
seeking or an information
and ambiguity component
to the right of that.
So here's my question.
If unless we say that
curiosity actually is a target,
which this paper says
is it's actually
a non target in the operation
and the formalism
actually points that out.
Then how do you set something up
like a neural net
to actually be curious?
Because we
we can be curious,
we can be non targeting
and find reward in that if we go
one direction
and find information gained in that
in another direction and they are,
they are completely different things.
They're not
seen in the
in the formalism as the same thing.
So I'm just curious whether
we're right because
as I said,
I don't know enough about neural nets
to know, but
aren't neural nets
constantly constrained
by having a target?
I think there's many ways to
answer that.
I am not sure if it would totally map
onto the difference
of supervised and unsupervised learning,
like supervised learning being
where labels are provided.
These x rays belong to this patient
category, these ones
belong to the alternate category.
I want you to get good,
but you know, don't over specify
don't over fit that distinction.
Supervised learning
unsupervised learning
is more along the lines of like
here's input
according to how your set up
embody the statistical regularities
in the structure
of the information that has been input.
And then that representation
allows like clustering
and subsequent analyzes
or the addition of labels later.
But it is predicated
in the training phase
upon the data or the cases being labels
does that.
Yeah, but the predication is not
curiosity is it.
That's my point is
that there is no curiosity
in what you just described.
Right.
It's like a pipeline
that is receiving
whatever information is being provided
and Cheerios really seems
to kind of break out of that.
And it's like, give me more examples.
And then the directed
curiosity would be like, I'm
looking for more examples of the label.
A
The undirected curiosity
would be more like
I just would like more examples.
So to, to ask, are we maybe Ali,
is it consciousness
if it doesn't have curiosity?
Well, I don't think so, because you see,
even in
unsupervised learning,
we don't necessarily
well, the neural networks
don't necessarily extract the
the the essence
of their training examples.
What they do is all
is to extract a
statistic prototype of their tokens,
the statistical prototype
of their training examples.
So actually
they can't recognize
a dog as a dog.
They just see patterns.
They just see statistical patterns
which they have learned
through their training process.
So they're not
they're not necessarily conscious
of the object of dog or cat or whatever.
What, what are what they try to do is
and in fact, in some cases,
well, sometimes we see that
they have in fact inferred
wrong the statistical prototypes
because of, well, insufficient
training examples or
well,
not appropriate training examples
or so on.
But in any case, what
I don't think we can
say that.
Well, neural networks because
because of their ability to recognize
these patterns, they necessarily
well,
have consciousness because well,
probably
in order to achieve consciousness, well,
other layers of cognitive
and even perceptual mechanisms
need to be deployed
if it had some other points.
But if you wanted to a
you'll stay on the curiosity topic.
And it was related to
what at the point
I was going to make up about belief
in desire,
you're clearly defining the words.
So there's specifically a,
you know, we're
going to take the PDI model
and use words like belief and desire to
use some relatively obscure
scientific model versus a, you know,
like a whole
historical review of the etymology.
And,
you know, how do we
how we defining of beliefs in desire,
you know, just curiosity,
have a desire to learn something,
your thoughts on purpose
that that means it's not goal driven.
And then how I would understand
belief and desire in terms of you.
So desires are biological urges
like reproduction
or survival in a for the emotions
or maybe all derivative
how you're going to put that out, where
if you're going to try to source
all of them from one pure desire
and all the other
desires are derivative,
or if you're going
have multiple desires,
and then you'd have to have some sort
of weighting function
to weight
the different desires,
and then beliefs are self-made
rules that come from our own cognition.
And that's where decision making comes
comes in.
And even, you know,
a rabbinic statement
in terms of free will,
that free will is implying
that you have the choice to make
the less desirous opinion,
that the less desires choice.
Like as a chess player,
if you're thinking like a
candidate moves an analysis tree,
is that in reality
are candidate
moves are just how we control our body?
And do we move our arm up or down
or the various controls
of our physical function?
But what are the candidate moves
and then how would the analysis tree and
decision making is it how would it come
that you would make the less desirous
decision?
Is it purely, you know, as a short term
versus long term?
And then the organization of you,
let's take a system like,
okay, I'm a Jew, I'm
a muslim, I'm an atheist
or I'm a capitalist,
I'm a communist
that we have these self directed
beliefs that control our behavior.
And if it's learning to do things like,
I can't steal,
God forbid,
I can't rape, I can't kill,
and that like my desire,
if the body tells me,
okay, see, attractive woman,
I want to have sexual relations
other than I have these beliefs
like that.
There's a system of rules and governance
that is a purely
because I can't get away with it
that I don't do it.
We don't rape still until because
we can't get away with it.
Or is there this self-imposed,
moralistic behavior
and that's coming down to what
belief means.
And then,
you know,
also,
if you're so curiosity,
you'd have to clearly define
curiosity.
If you're talking about neural nets
that, you know,
can a computer
just learn for its own sake
and even can a human
just learn for its own sake that,
you know,
we're participating these discussions?
Purely because I enjoy
figuring things out,
even if it has no practical
implication to,
you know,
some primal directive of survival
or reproduction
or however you're going to understand
these primal directives.
And then,
you know, the equation
be similar to a chess
algorithm for a computer where
it would appear that you could add
in weighting factors,
that you could programed this
into the equations
and you have some constants
that would be weighting factors.
So if you did have
just one primal directive
of survival or two primal directives
of reproduction and survival,
and then you could give
those weighting factors,
or you could have
a feedback mechanism
with the environment, and then,
you know,
where do the belief comes in the self
made rules?
And then how do that
how are those weighting
factors calculated in decision making
and what does it mean
to make a decision?
Is it possible
that we make the least
desirous decision?
And if we can't make the
less desirous decision,
do we not
have free will?
Thanks.
So Jonathan Schock
made a great point,
which is that deep neural networks
applied to reinforcement
learning can include curiosity
as an explicit factor.
It guides the agent to states
which it has about
which it has the most uncertainty.
So it's a term
which makes it rewarding
to explore currently unexplored states.
And then just
to provide a recent example,
here's a way in which a neural network
architecture was used
certainly worthy of more exploration,
and at a first pass, or at least just
qualitatively,
one way to think about that,
and then we'll come to
how Curiosity was described
in the text, is in active inference,
we have
a imperative for action selection
that includes a pragmatic
and an epistemic component,
whereas a pragmatic
absolutist perspective
like reinforcement
learning needs
to generate
these modules
and alternate architectures
such that information seeking
curiosity can be coerced into
a reward framework.
I mean, what is the next question
going to be?
Well, it's
rewarding to gain information.
Oh, what kind of information?
How much information,
how are we going to learn the parameters
on our curiosity model
and so on
and so active inference
as a first principles approach
for this kind
of artificially intelligent system
allows us to include at the base level
both an objective
achieving and a pure curiosity
element.
Dean And then we'll
look at how they talk about curiosity.
Thanks, Daniel.
So
as a as is historically
been the case for point two's,
I'll just left
and I was going to ask him
this question, okay.
Because he's still here.
So David went after the one
and now just what
you were just sharing with us here,
I wondered without putting words,
can I get a clarification?
I think one of the things that you're
trying to make clear or
or at least bring into the card
is that prioritization,
which is the sort of the value
weighting aspect
of how we see the world, is not ordering
the kind of placing
of a formalism down on paper
that includes rules
like equals
and plus and minus in the FPP
or the sort of extended and variation
is that in not oversimplifying
what you want us to make clear that
that having a evaluating
is not the same,
that kind of prioritization is not
the same as being able to formally set
and order.
Well, I'm a dualist, so.
Like I'm trying to.
I think I could use these equations
for dualistic purposes
and you could just factor
in a waiting factor
for these higher order rules.
And then,
you know,
so my system would have some sort of
struggle between
two separate realms of material
and spiritual realm.
So that's your personally
how I'm I'm looking at it.
But, you know,
I can attempt to understand it from
just the materialistic realm
and how the equations
of your would apply.
And then if there's competing factors,
what's the origin
of those competing factors?
So if you just put
your desires, our biological,
animalistic urges and beliefs are self
created rules of cognition,
and then you want to have
a separate function
like curiosity, where we're curiosity,
maybe benefits
the purpose of making beliefs
which would
later come to become higher order rules.
And
or if you want to have
the ability to have
behavior that has no purpose,
that I just enjoy understanding things,
maybe that understanding
will help me
make better, higher order rules.
And even then saying, oh,
like you're saying for the equation,
because here we have these equations
and it's free energy.
And, you know, so the purpose is to
minimize it,
minimize the
at least in principle, it eliminates
limit energy usage.
And so if you're looking like, well,
why did I do that?
Was like,
you know, dummy, didn't
you look at the equation?
It was
it was the free energy principle
you did to minimize energy usage.
And, you know,
so if we're just saying that that that's
the origin of all human behavior
from an element of a static
sense and
you're from the false psychology.
That's why I said, if
I'm taking a dualistic perspective
where these higher order rules
are coming from a non material plane,
but I think they could be modeled
into the equations.
Thanks.
Also, free energy
minimization doesn't entail
the actual minimal possible
energy usage,
though some people have made
that accidentally
or intentionally a claim.
It isn't what those equations
as they're being used here
necessarily represent, but it could
there could be a system
that thrives optimally
based upon reducing energy usage.
But also there are situations
where free energy minimization
in the path of least action
or not, the lowest energy consumption
was that
short term versus long term thing?
Long term
it is,
but it's just short
term versus long term
decision making in the
as opposed to a dualistic
the predictive mind.
That thing is not dualistic,
spiritual versus material.
It's a single, materialistic
in its short term versus long term.
Okay.
Let's
think about that
in the context of of curiosity,
how they're describing so
gee, expected free energy of policies.
It's like the policies are enumerated
and then is calculated for them reflects
the inferred value of each policy based
upon beliefs.
Beliefs are p of o sub t
condition on pi.
So the distribution of outcomes
conditioned upon policies.
If I go left,
what do I expect to see if I go right?
What do I expect to see? That's a belief
and the belief distribution
about observations
conditioned upon hidden
states of the world.
If there is food there,
then what observations
will I expect to see
and desired outcomes, which is,
as we've explored in 37 in User's Guide,
there's this dual implication
of the P of O distribution
and active inference as what is expected
as well as preferred,
because we reduce our surprise
about the expected
slash preferred outcome distribution,
and that is how the desired outcomes
are realized,
not by providing a higher reward
or value
to increasingly preferred states,
but rather
treating the preference distribution
as expectations
which allows us to use surprises
and surprising
bounding approaches towards achieving
preferences.
So how do they
talk about desire and curiosity?
They're suggesting that these drives
so this is in earlier
we talked about there's
the two ways to talk about desire,
the specific target of desire
as a desire
like I desire
a cube of tungsten or something.
And then there's the drive
that is associated with desire.
What made the person do it?
Desire in the abstract,
curiosity drives
discovery of what is not yet known
and thus has no preconceived target.
However, one could also say
that it has a semi
formed concept of target
because one could be like
curious about something and
then curiosity would be satiated
by something else,
something but not something else.
So in that case,
there was some of
something of a prior
on, what they were looking for
the claim
that curiosity is not cognitive,
so desire related
might seem suspect on the grounds.
It could also be characterized
as simply the desire to learn
qualitatively.
And this in turn could be conceived
as the desire
that one's beliefs
are as precise as possible, even though,
especially in the short term, learning
sometimes feels like
it reduces our precision.
However, the mathematics
allow us to motivate
a genuine distinction here, specifically
changing outcomes to minimize
the scale divergence in the risk term.
In if he is a fundamentally different
sort of process
for minimizing the ambiguity term.
So the key divergence is on the
left side here
and the ambiguity term
is on the right side here.
Here's the equation
2.6 from the textbook
and it's it's in a different order.
But just to see here's risk
with the scale divergence
and then here's expected ambiguity
with an H
for the entropy calculation,
the latter of
which is the ambiguity term
does not care
how uncertainty is resolved so long
it is resolved.
There's no preference
for becoming more confident
in one possible belief over another,
whereas the reduction of uncertainty
by reducing the scale divergence is
what is bringing us into alignment
with our preferences slash expectations.
Hence
that is a much more targeted
form of curiosity
in that it allows for goal
directed information seeking
and then they write.
At a minimum,
the psychological concept of curiosity
corresponds
to a very different type of desire,
with a distinct counterpart in Die Dean
Yeah,
that's perfect, because
what I wanted to say was that
I think that
that curiosity
really points to that risk.
And the reason I say
that is because you may find that
when the ambiguity is removed,
surprises a happy one or a not.
So happy one.
And I think that's
that's kind of important
here, too, to see sort of the
it's it's hard to say, as it says here.
It's however,
the claim
that curiosity is non-cognitive
might seem suspect on the grounds.
It could also be characterized
as simply just the desire to learn that
before learning you,
you're you're sort of in a
in a ambiguous state.
Will it be a happy surprise
or will it be an unhappy surprise?
And so I think this this kind of pulls
that out. You
know,
the ambiguity
applies a certain amount of risk.
But then you have to
you have to act
in the act of inference aspect of it
to determine whether or not the surprise
or let the other side of it
is actually good or not so good.
So I think that's
where the curiosity arm of this
comes to the fore.
It is non targeted
until it actually has been realized
or somehow materialized, whereas the
the targeted stuff, the desire stuff
and be part of your plan.
I'm not sure whether the curiosity fits
as conveniently as the desire does.
And just one short on
that is we
we see a conditioning on policy
right, in a few different places.
So it'd be interesting to think about
where does planning to learn
come into play
and in what ways
is planning to learn directed
or what if you plan to
have undirected learning
or all these
other combinations, do it.
Yeah, I'm
not sure if it would
exactly fit in with the equations,
but I'm thinking here, like Maslow's
hierarchy of needs are defined in terms
the free energy principle, where
you sort of say curiosity
requires excess energy.
So if you're on the first rung
of the hierarchy
that you have limited energy to apply
towards curiosity.
And if you do have energy to apply
towards curiosity,
you're going to be best off
to be curious about things
that will directly apply to,
you know, your security,
you know, your food
or the primal directives as opposed to,
you know,
if you move up, up the hierarchy,
at least put this into Maslow's
hierarchy, where the
you know, there's less risk
associated with curiosity,
that maybe you've achieved
more leisure activity
and then therefore have more
energy to expand towards curiosity,
that you could reach
the highest levels of Maslow's hierarchy
and focus on
your ideals and what is the meaning
of truth or understanding of science.
But it would still be
you, however, you're defining
the free energy principle
that you have some sort
of a conservation of energy
and curiosity is an expansion of energy
that is limited.
But more resources could be allocated,
so to say, energy resources to curiosity
if it makes the whole, you know, a
unified person more more
efficient, then, you know,
they become more secure,
more safe, more social acceptance
and so on.
And therefore,
they're more energy
to expand towards curiosity.
Thanks, Ali.
I also think it might be helpful to
mention the neural basis
for these surprise appraisals, because
you see, as we know,
we have two systems of thinking system
one system, two things really
sketched out by
Kahneman and diversity
or fast
track and slow
track of reacting to stimuli.
So in the fast track,
well, the stimuli
bypassed the sensory cortex
and go directly from thalamus
to amygdala. Right?
So our first reaction,
our immediate reaction to every surprise
would be something
quite similar to fear.
But then after appraising
that stimuli stimulus
after going through the sensory cortex
and then amygdala and then hippocampus,
then we can appraise,
we can evaluate that
surprise as being positive or negative.
And as a result of that,
we get a positive or negative
valence affect.
So
in summary,
well, every surprise,
I mean, either positive or negative,
it could be at first
and at the very first moment be
a kind of
negative
can induce a negative
valence emotion in us.
Yes.
I brought in some of the quotes
from this paper,
habitual and reflective control
and hierarchical predictive coding.
It's from 2021 and it's by Kinghorn,
Milledge and Buckley.
So they directly connect
hierarchical predictive
coding architectures
which when they consider action,
have a lot to do with active inference
in terms of
thinking fast and slow
like you had just brought up.
So they wrote on this view
fast actions may be triggered
using only the lower levels
of the hierarchical
predictive coding schema,
whereas more deliberative actions
need higher layers.
We demonstrate that HPC can distribute
learning throughout its hierarchy
with higher layers
called into use only as required.
So that is very interesting.
We think about
going back to the idea
I distinction from this paper,
it's a hybrid model, albeit one
where the motor
spatial control is continuous or model
that is continuous,
and then there's a more discrete,
more mental or cognitive model
that's like thinking slow.
So it's almost like there's thinking
fast and slow
even within the mind
and then there's thinking with the body.
And that's like even a lower level.
I don't think even by thinking fast
they weren't
talking about the reflex arc,
but there be hierarchical modeling
even there.
So
it
what are these
nested models that are slower?
How do those develop?
Are they related to the
physical architecture
of our on board machinery?
To what extent do they involve
so many of our off sourced
or extended cognitive phenomena like our
our colleagues,
like our social networks,
our books
and learning the social structures
that scaffold our beliefs and so on.
There's a lot of interesting pieces
there.
What would be a good direction to go
in this second?
Half of the two
we had targeted non-targeted?
Is there anything there that's not
covered by the curiosity discussion?
Is there
a unmuted and yes, go for it.
Sorry about that.
Yeah, I think we pretty much
wrestled that one to the ground.
Okay, do it.
Yeah. Conception for targeted.
I'm calling the unified AI in terms of,
you know, maybe like the ant colony
where.
You've you
you could look at it
like the ants are all functioning
personally with their own,
your directive behavior
and it just works out
that they're directed or as a unit.
But even in like a human,
whether there's a unified
of the human cells, like even sense
perception that,
you know,
it's easier to look at it like our our,
you know, like I mentioned, we have 100
like almost
100 million
cones and rods in our eyes
that are receiving photons
at every given instant.
And we just look at it
like they're actors
acting in a unified manner.
But even
that requires some
sort of targeted behavior
that the, you know,
for for even direct motor motor control
that our cells in our given body
are acting in a unified manner.
And could you
you take the free energy principle to
a cellular level and say, well, cells
will act in a unified way
if it's in accordance
with the free energy principle.
But if it wasn't in accordance
with the free energy
principle,
then cells don't act in a unified,
targeted way
and act according to their own levels.
I'm not sure if you could take that to
the cellular level
for even things like sense perception,
motor control,
like when ARM wants to go this way
and one wants to go that way,
and how do we have this unified control?
It's interesting thing about
what would it
what would make something Concord
or not with ATP because it's
a description framework
here is where in
from life from 25 with professor Levin
here's even in the colony example
where different substance and and cancer
and and like other situations
like biofilms were modeled this way
that there can be coherence
within each cone, so to speak.
A
I don't know if this moves us
closer
to understanding
the experience of the eye or whether
there is in fundamental a unified eye.
But the cells in the estimates
body can be understood
as undergoing coherent behavior.
Then estimates can, colony can,
and then different people
have taken different perspectives
on what makes one level of analysis
more relevant
than others,
like an evolutionary perspective
is that
the unit of selection is granted
some special power.
A information processing perspective
or integrated information
theory might highlight what happens.
Information within and across levels.
Let's look at the their
dark room experiment.
We kind of
came to a little bit last time,
but what did anyone think their figure
and simulation spoke to?
How was it adding
details or
information that weren't a presence
in the
more formalism and qualitative
driven other sections of the paper?
I have a question.
I don't know if I have an
interpretation of it.
When others when others looked at this
as it's now graphed out,
did they see ambiguity removal
or did they see
and an entropy question being resolved?
Because what I saw was the latter.
I, I kind of saw that
something, something appeared
with more information
gained or something disappeared.
If there was no sense that, that,
that the change of the ambiguity state
was going to make any difference.
So I'm kind of curious
what others, how others interpreted the
the actual data as it as it laid out
post hoc because this is all post hoc.
This is just comparing.
..7.32.99.01
in terms of the does
in terms of the desire, strength.
And I think
they used the term urgency in the paper
going right?
Yes.
Well, on on the left side.
Okay.
So time
as there's
time is moving from left to right.
There's an entity that doesn't desire
they don't have a preference
for achieving ice cream.
And in this simulation run,
they observed that
they were in the dark room
and they
picked the decision to flip a switch.
They then went to the right.
And they ended up
not finding that they got ice
cream.
The Weak Desire agent first
flips the switch
and then
with higher confidence goes to the left
and they end up realizing ice cream
in this case of the strong desire agent,
even though
they have
uncertainty about going left
or right initially, they're in a hurry
or it's urgent
and they go left immediately.
And that turns out that it does achieve
getting the ice cream
one one know is like
these are only showing
one run of each of those simulations.
So it's like does the
no desire entity always go to the right
or is that a 5050?
How have people used the BVI
to do quantitative modeling of behavior?
Are moving their verbal
and formal arguments
from above in the paper
into a form factor
that will be more amenable or palatable
to people
who are already using these models to do
behavioral
well.
I think the beauty
I mean, strictly from the
from the standpoint of here's
what we're watched this agent do,
it kind of it kind of had a 5050 choice.
It was playing
more in the geometry space.
How this is represented
is more
sort of the Bayesian distribution piece.
Right.
So you've got a
a percentage of of an area
as you're moving from left to right
that's either
darkened or remains agnostic.
It doesn't it doesn't sort of change
what what the outcome or what
the the matching of an outcome and
the expected free energy are.
So I think that it just brings
more information to the
to the observation
of what's actually going on
when when the lights either do go on
or don't go on
because that first one,
the lights
don't go on, I think, and the agent
either stumbles
to the right place or doesn't,
but they don't care.
But I do think that what happens is
you can have geometry only
or you can have geometry and
a proportion or distribution.
And I think that's what this is
kind of laying out for us, that you've
now you've got more information.
And with more information,
hopefully you've got less,
less
in variance.
You've got more variance
being described here than you would
if you left it
with a geometric level alone.
So make sense.
Yes.
And they they follow up
after the figure
that this magnitude mapping, it's giving
not just some theoretical detail
to this mapping.
And they provide
several citations,
many recently with Smith and others
where it's
used in many different contexts.
And then I kind of found it
a also interesting
in the following
sentences after the paragraph that
I had just quoted
there, this motivating force
could be corresponding to the magnitude
of the scale divergence.
Scale divergence
between the Q distribution
of observations
conditioned upon policy divergence with
the preference distribution P of up
within the expected free energy.
So that's one of the terms
that we've looked at in the GAAP
either asked her
not to ambiguity term with entropy.
This is because
stronger preference values
over rewarding outcomes in p of of t
increase the kill divergence
and lead the agent seek
reward over information.
Gain.
So there's still a knob,
maybe
multiple that are slightly interacting.
There's a knob by which more
pure curiosity
that would be just the ambiguity
resolving but undirected
mixtures of pure curiosity
and directed curiosity, weak preferences
with a lot of openness
and increasingly sharp
preference distributions induce
increasingly urgent,
pragmatic, value seeking outcomes
and
there's a lot of
funny things
that come to mind, like
a question for one person
might be a survival question
for another,
it might be a research question.
For another,
it might be like a pure curiosity.
Where's the oxygen in this room?
Is that a survival question?
Is that just,
you know,
again, are you researching
distributions in rooms
so you have a target to understand that?
Or are you just curious about that
thought of Dean? Then do it.
Think that I Daniel that
clearly speaks to a dividend
and we were both mentioning in terms of
so what's your timeframe here, right?
So you take off
and you have a bird strike
and now you don't have enough time
to land anywhere on the river.
Is that curiosity?
It's that desire.
Is that
what is that in terms of
how much time do you have now to manage
the risk
aspect of
this this situation
you now find yourself under?
It's certainly survival.
But yeah, what what what percentages
or what proportions
of each
one of these different
parts of the equation
are being calculated at any given moment
relative to the overall time frame
that you're now constrained under.
So,
yes, do it.
I mean, you just look at the
refrigerator example that Walker had.
I've been curious,
you know, earlier during the day
about the layout of the room.
I might have remembered
how to get to the fridge later,
but I didn't extend that mental energy.
So here I am hungry
and I don't know my surroundings.
And so you have the level of
if curiosity
could have provided benefit, but now
at this point,
you know,
you have
the risk factor
while I enjoy myself or eat.
And I was thinking,
you know,
like chess or something like, okay, like
the Alpha Zero is programed
with,
you know,
the most powerful computers
for hours and hours
to just understand the game
and then later
it's able to take that and win.
So like as a person,
it's like, okay,
I really just like thinking
about chess and understand the
but then you look at what
I have to reproduce,
I have to see to the
success of my children
and the offspring.
I have to,
you know, make money and survive and.
So, you know,
maybe I could become
a professional chess player
or something like that,
but then you would come in and well,
if my goal is to,
you know,
reproduce
and see the success of my offspring and,
you know, make money and survive,
there's better methods to do that
than becoming a
professional chess player,
even like act of inference
that, okay,
I'm curious about how that stuff works,
but it's probably
not going to help me reproduce
or make a living.
And if I tried to,
you know,
take my curiosity about consciousness
and use that to benefit reproduction
or make it or making a living,
it's unlikely to see that much
fruition.
But at the same time, the
I mean, the power of curiosity,
you don't know
how it's going to benefit you.
So the ice cream example,
you know, if we
if we had a meeting in the kitchen,
you know, during the day
and then we all go back to our rooms
to go to sleep,
and then we're hungry at night.
The person who was just curious
about how the room
was laid out is going to be able to,
you know,
likely retrieve
the ice cream
without any injury,
as were the person who didn't
expand the energy
to be curious about the layer
layout of the room may not achieve
the ice cream.
And that's why
I like in my in my own head
it may not be
directly to this paper,
but it could be in folk psychology.
It would be to
you map this to something
like Maslow's hierarchy of rules,
which would be in line with neural
neural nets,
that there would be some sort of
higher order rules
and some sort of ability to
put the expansion of more energy.
Like, okay, like
I thought about chess
and now I'm winning
and I've achieved a little bit
of social standing or,
you know, won a little prize money
or even school.
I was curious about consciousness.
Now I got a bachelor's degree
and I have enough
proficiency to, you know,
get a job and support a family.
And now I could exert
even more energy to it.
But at the time of the pure curiosity,
you don't know how it may
you actually benefit you
in terms of reward, great points
that it's almost like jumping
through different hoops
what it might be best
accomplished, pure curiosity
at a future time point.
So in in again that survival
research and pure curiosity trilemma
there's times
we're being driven by one or the other,
helps us move
through complex real world.
If we knew
the whole story from the beginning,
then we could just follow along.
But in a highly information worlds
where we don't want our priors to
lead to ruin, basically,
then pure curiosity and research
help
bring things within our survivable limit
into information gathering spaces
that we wouldn't
necessarily have traveled to
limited resources.
I don't know if we could program
that also into the computer.
Also like the limit of resources.
And if that
if you interpret free energy
principle in general
to be a definition of limited
energy resources.
Ali
Well, you're adding to my
own previous comments about the
subject of consciousness and
I personally believe
that the nature of consciousness
is ultimately computational,
and so it's amenable to modeling and
this simulated simulation.
But we're we're just not there yet.
But well,
one possible approach to
to achieve such model
could be potentially
the active inference approach
or other related approaches.
But you see, curiosity
is just one aspect of consciousness.
And I think it should
it could probably be helpful
to distinguish
between the artificial curiosity
and the experience of curiosity
or the phenomenology of the curiosity.
What we see here is
the agent
that simulates the artificial curiosity
and not it's not exactly
ice morphic with the experience
we get from our drive to our information
seeking drives.
And in fact, in this paper,
I think it was in page
28.
Yes, it's in page 28
that they states that
we have not addressed questions
about the structure of generative model
would need in order to account
for experience of beliefs and desires.
So well, at least in this paper,
we're not dealing with
the actual experience of curiosity.
We're just trying to somehow model
and simulate the artificial curiosity.
In fact, this term
artificial curiosity
is one favored by our president himself
in his various other lectures.
Yes, very good point.
And it relates to kind
of the experience view
from the inside
versus the behavioral modeling view
from the outside.
A curious particle or a curious forager
might be engaging
in some kind of behavior,
but that isn't the same thing
as the experience of.
But they do provide references to other
work, like including work
that has been discussed
previously on Live Streams
with White and Ryan Smith
on report paradigms of consciousness.
As we
head towards the end here,
I thought this was very interesting
in the section before the conclusion.
11 Free Energy
Principle and Direction of Fit.
And this is kind of a good section to
to carry out
and bring forward
into our other discussions on active
for any organism described by the FP.
The description will contain
an implicitly normative state elements
about the states.
The organism should be in
and can be described
as having cognitive desire
like direction of fit.
So there's a preference distribution
and as this papers building up
it can have an interpretation as desire.
Being a targeted desire,
even beyond the case
of forward looking decision
making agents.
Not all
Bayesian beliefs
in the FP
formalism are best characterized as docs
being about belief docs ology.
This perspective
may expand upon current discussion
in the FIP literature,
where it is
fairly prominent
to discuss as if beliefs
in simple systems
whether a mere active entity
like a pendulum
or adaptive active entities
and just say, I'm not saying
that it really believes
that it's acting as if it believes that
that conform to the FIP here.
Our point is
they can also equally be described
as having as if desires
belief entered the active
lexicon slash ontology,
perhaps because belief is used also
in Bayesian statistics.
Distributions more generally
are called beliefs,
also disjoint from the phenomenology
of experiencing a belief,
but rather that's just called belief.
Updating is like a process
in Bayesian statistics.
This paper kind of closes
the loop with belief,
not towards phenomenology,
but stapling together
some of the Bayesian
distributional usage of the term
belief with the docs gnostic
being
about belief, the about
ness of those Bayesian beliefs
is the folk
psychological concept of belief.
By making that mapping
and connecting the formalism as a whole,
or at least in the core equations
like the ethnology to the BD model,
it also allows them to identify
which Bayesian
belief distributions
map to belief in the BDA
and Bayesian belief distributions
map to d to the desires in the die.
And so to the extent
that somebody can say
a system has an as if belief
implicitly in a folk psychological way,
we can also talk about
as if desires
that helps
partition
but not disregard
the discussion around
what different systems
the classic you know
what is it like to be X but it
at least
according to this argument
and perspective, authorizes usage
of intentions and desires
intentions arising
from basically the combination
of the beliefs and the desires
in the VDI
and talking about
active systems as if they have desires.
What is that simulation desires of?
And then using its beliefs
and desires
to explain its intentional behavior,
not the experience
of intentionality, experience
of belief,
experience of desire,
but using them in this
view, from the outside,
more deflationary perspective.
So that's quite interesting.
And I think something that
will be
we'll see how it catches on
and which will
are the other sections
that people want to talk about or what
will they carry forward into their
post?
46 Life?
I think, Daniel, a couple of things.
I think the desire is the part
that you're just talking about.
There are not sure that it's specific
in nature.
I think it's more generalizable
and sort of that scale three
is that there's
to to
some extent that David brought up.
I think that when you when you
when you start getting getting to know
active interests
a little bit
more and I'll speak
from personal experience
with a focus,
a little bit of
sort of personal grooming,
you become one
heck of an attractive state.
And so
I think you might not make
money off of that, but at this point.
But I think as you get more
comfortable with the kind of being able
to take the information and
use it
across a variety
of different situations, it's
it's actually is quite helpful.
I don't think I'll
ever get rich off of it
at this point,
but it is kind of interesting how it's
I think, it is growing
in terms of the amount of attention
that it's getting. So that's kind of my
my two takes on this so far.
So you're saying it might
influence fitness?
I think it might down the road.
As long as we have enough time and scale
that,
you know,
I've been coaching chess for a while
and mostly to youth,
and I'm used to explaining
somewhat know these concepts.
Like I want to say that
people who are just curious about chess
and how
the patterns work and other pieces
work often
improve much faster
than people who desire to win,
and that a lot of times
people will reach a certain strength
and then the curiosity diminishes
and it's just their desire to win,
which isn't enough
that, you know,
it's just like,
I want to spend my night thinking
about these patterns
versus like I really want to win
and have some sort of practical
benefit from my efforts.
So I have my own
personal goals
that brought me to active inference
because I was looking for my own tools
to advance my own research
and came on to active inference as
a method or tool that even though,
you know,
it appeared
that the majority of people are using it
for a different purpose,
that I would be able to rework it
for my own purpose.
But because it's an
interdisciplinary study
and like,
you know, I'm an engineer
and that like engineering usually works
that way
where someone has
professional certification,
they sign off
and you could expect
that they did their part right
and it's going to work and you could,
you know, attach
that module to your module
and both modules
going to do
what they said they're going to do.
And then,
you know, the curiosity will do.
I really want to understand
how your module works.
You know,
do I really care
about Dean and Ali's research or,
you know, do
I just want to trust
that their module works
and I'm going to be able
to attach that to my module
to make make something more powerful.
And both are probably true to it,
you know, to
your limited
energy,
limited resources that, you know,
that I would like to understand.
Dean And at least module
to the best of my ability, but energy,
time allocation of
resources are limited.
But then, you know, certainly
you had a module
that would help my module
and we could plug them in together and,
you know,
create a more powerful interface
so that I'm bullish about
active inference and as a framework
that will benefit,
you know,
the more and more people
who get involved.
And I'm seeing my own direction
in my own research.
I, you know,
I think this will be useful.
And I even think I got
Jennifer, I think joined the discord.
And I mentioned to a few other people
that that might be able
advance their research
and then try to understand,
you know, the current existing modules
that are out there.
You know, within the active inference.
And you know,
I've mentioned the importance
of interdisciplinary studies
for, you know, big issues.
You know,
none of us are going to figure this out.
It's going to take
interdisciplinary studies,
and none of us are going to be able
to understand
all of the disciplines necessary
to piece together the bigger puzzle.
Nice. Thank you. Yes.
Interesting point about the curiosity
driven learning
and how that can be like a
but even paradoxically more successful
approach or mentality
to set off on a journey,
a learning journey with.
I just think about somebody
trying to
learn organic chemistry,
which I tutored for many years,
and people who set themselves up
for the pragmatic value
and said, I want this outcome.
Sometimes they achieve the outcome.
Other times they didn't,
but it set up a lot of psychology
around
not achieving the outcome
when it didn't happen.
On the expected timeline
and a lot of like
secondary cascading failures.
However,
there's also the the clear counterpoint,
which is but if we don't
want the higher grade, then
like if we're just going to be curious
about learning
organic chemistry,
like my finals in six weeks.
So how are we going to balance the
and the curiosity?
And I think maybe even
this paper helped us look at one way,
which is keep the preference direction,
but understand
how the urgency of your preference
influences the way that you take action.
And just think about what what if you
what if your final was tomorrow?
How would you go about it?
Okay.
Now, what if the final was in 100 years?
How would you go about it?
Where are we in that continuum?
Do we have time for curiosity
and for openness,
or is this
an actual emergency situation?
And then we can triage where there is
an emergency
organic chemistry situation,
but also hold space for curiosity
and openness.
And even in the emergency,
there has to be information seeking
it just more directed
information seeking.
Okay, we're going to work
through the practice tests
and that's
what we're going to have time for.
There's still is going
to be information seeking,
but not of the same kind.
If we had more time
to kind of space out,
even though in a alternate slash
preferable world,
perhaps that's the better way
to learn, the more fun way to learn, or
so on.
Any other thoughts?
Well, one of the things
I really like about
active insurance
research is
the willingness
of the researchers in this area to
seriously address the criticisms
instead of just judging them and
their willingness to to constantly
improving, update the theory
in order to
fill the fill the gaps and well,
and also address the
well, the weakness or any
any weakness or loophole
in the in the theory.
And that's very
liberating
to see such a active area of research
going going forward
in a very determined and also
very open minded, open minded way.
And.
Well,
that's one of the things that I think
sets it apart from
other than some other
research areas today.
It's what we prefer.
It's what we expect
to.
We're curious about it.
Okay,
Dean, Ali, David,
thanks a lot for this fun discussion.
And Ryan Maxwell
and Alex for this paper,
it really capped off a long
run of livestreams. We've had
quite a nice sequence
going back to the beginning
of this year,
getting through many, many discussions.
Next week, we're going to have
the second quarterly roundtable meeting
and then we'll have July off
of paper discussions
and we'll be coming back in August with
paper discussions.
We don't know
exactly what they're going to be,
but we know some of them.
And we have a few guest streams
and other streams coming up.
But
yeah, it's been a nice run.
The lab meeting
next week
will be a great cup to this season
slash semester
and then we'll come back
for the end of 2022
with some new changes
that I think people
will be really excited about.
So thanks everybody and see you later.
Thanks, Dana. Thanks, everyone.
Thanks a lot.